when i coded tools i really wanted them
to be easy to use because people use
them all the time and they want things
to be comfortable you know they don't
want to spend a lot of time in your
program they just wanted to work for
them
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders meet danish pakovsky group
leader at weka io
danny is originally a systems developer
and security researcher having served in
various roles in the technological unit
and 8200
he then pivoted from cyber and for the
last four years has been working in weka
io a storage startup developing the
fastest distributed file system in the
world which enables modern workloads to
reach their full potential
he first joined as a developer and in
the last couple of years as a team and
group leader
in weka he is managing the product's
control plane bridging the gap between a
highly complex and hard to understand
product and end users who want
simplicity usability and user experience
danish pakovsky welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you i'm good happy to be
here thank you so much for being here i
i love talking you know usually you know
entrepreneurs entrepreneur investor
investor engineer to engineer and so you
have a really interesting background
transitioning from cyber to a weka io an
incredible israeli company um that's in
the storage space but but you know the
really interesting transition in my
perspective is a transition from you
know a developer an engineer to a team
leader so with the responsibility of
leading other engineers and then a group
leader obviously with much more
with much more responsibility and i'd
love to pick your brain on sort of you
know what that's like and how that
translates into your own personal
journey of leadership
but i want you to get me started with
revenge of the nerds because i watched
that show
and i really did i did watch that show
and so i know you better than you think
i know you so tell me a little bit about
that experience
well uh so i was pretty young you know i
was 12 or 13 i think um and i wasn't
like an institute for like gifted
children we went for one day a week and
they were looking for people who were
also very smart but also you know like
look good on camera
because you know it's television of
course and uh and we had some you know
interviews and stuff like that and then
they chose me and we started filming so
first of all it's it's really
interesting to be behind like behind the
scenes and behind the camera and the
show itself was pretty interesting you
know we had different tasks i learned to
solve a rubik's cube um
and i had to face some things that you
know never faced before um and
essentially the the way i went down is i
went down in a task where we needed to
touch like uh you know like worms and
cockroaches and stuff like that and we
were supposed to recognize them and then
take them out of like this canister and
i recognized everything but i could not
touch them it's like my biggest phobia
so
that's where how i felt that i fell down
and then you know rubik's cube i i
solved them really quickly now but i
failed to do that on the show
and uh you know at least i wasn't the
first to go down i was like fifth so i i
think that that that's always the that's
always the most important milestone of
course hey what was that
don't get out first
was it stressful fun
what was what was the experience like
for you you know as a kid going on a
show that is sort of you know testing
you know your intellectual abilities you
know
on television with for with friends and
family obviously going to be watching
this
yeah so i think i didn't understand the
implications at the time you know it was
just sounded like a fun experience
sounded cool and the challenges
themselves were really cool so it was
fun but then you know
i'm a young kid at age 12 13 again so
when i went out of the show it was like
pretty traumatic you know it's like i i
cried a lot and it was very difficult to
you know get torn out of it because it's
reality you know it's one one or two
wrong moves and then you go out
and
so it was difficult for me to accept
being in the show for several years
um but now i'm pretty open about it and
it's you know it's really like just a
fun fact
um for me
uh yeah and it was also i will say that
it was really interesting to just see
how television is being made you know
i i don't see that usually all the
testimonies and stuff i think i i think
that it's you know it's intellectually
fascinating to see a process
so complicated take place and at the end
you know the the it then can is being
condensed to mere minutes of of you know
entertainment but there's a whole
operation and logistics that goes behind
it you know so transitioning from that
to you know engineering mindset so
you're an engineer at heart you know
and in your mind
why why engineering so why computer
science why engineering for you
first of all because it's interesting
and it's challenging you know like uh
especially in weka we solve extremely
deep problems we need to go about doing
distributed algorithms do everything
fast do everything efficient everything
performance and it's just interesting
it's interesting to analyze and look at
results look at data
understand that you're doing an impact
like if if i'm if i want to improve some
algorithm so i'm looking at data i
understand that right now some process
takes 35 seconds and
i think i have an idea of how to make it
two seconds so i'm writing my code then
i'm looking at data again i understand i
made an improvement and understand i'm
giving value to someone right so whether
it be in the army where the value is you
know like national security and whether
it be it weka where the value is you
know someone's doing genomics faster
someone's doing ai faster
improving people's lives like we're a
platform that allows that so me
as an engineer i'm looking at how what
i'm doing is improving people's lives
and value for companies i love it and so
if you're if you're now you know going
from engineer to a team leader you're no
longer responsible yourself necessary
for all the code that is being deployed
but now you have to actually exert
leadership
a probably a completely different you
know mindset and you know
work that in your day-to-day so was that
was that a trivial thing for you to to
know that you want to do that you're
that you want to lead teams and you want
to be sort of a leader in the
engineering world
so it wasn't something that i initially
thought about a lot when i started work
um and
my company i i had some experiences of
mentoring people both in the army and in
my current company um but um the
sort of the mindset indeed changes but
it's not that i'm not responsible for
code anymore like i'm i really am still
responsible a lot for a lot of the
quality of the code i'm still doing a
lot of code reviews i'm still pushing
fixes and doing bugs myself like i'm i
am connecting to customer environments
to production systems and fixing stuff
you know when stuff breaks um
but the mindset indeed changes um i also
like i had like a very
bad experience transitioning into the
role it was it's december 2019 i broke
an ankle
about like maybe maybe five days after
starting the new role and so was at home
for weeks and so you started remote
before the rest of the world
yeah exactly star remote before the rest
of everybody and you know i'm sitting
sitting at home with my broken ankle and
after a few weeks the pain subsides a
little and then you're just bored and
you know you're like
i'm supposed to be like leading like
four or five people right now and
telling them you know like
helping them and
and giving them tasks and stuff like
that and it's
it's not happening so i started going
back to work pretty early but not you
know
not physically but remote uh remote and
then you know march 2020 so i'm just
starting to walk again with a cane
and everything closes and remote becomes
the standard and this is my experience
you know my first experience leading a
team is remote
and
it's it's so different you know it's
like i i'm used to
to an experience where the team leader
sits with people in the room he sees
everything he sees the problem they're
encountering you know um they're talking
about a problem they're experiencing and
you know you you hear it you can choose
whether you want to intervene or not
depending on on stuff you know like
maybe i want someone to experience the
problem on their own and improve and
maybe i want to just like wait this is
going to waste him a couple of days and
let's just solve this in 10 minutes um
but and this just disappears right
because kobe then everyone's remote so
we try doing some stuff you know like uh
sitting in zoom rooms together like that
but it's very very different very
different and um it's yeah and and even
like the experience of think about me as
a team leader so now i'm starting to
recruit people so i did interviews
before and at weka and now i'm starting
to recruit people who never went to the
office and i have a person who's coming
to the you know who i recruited who did
the entire uh
interview process and his first day in
the office is his first time seeing the
office
this is i believe very different from
what you usually experience as a manager
i can only imagine this is the standard
now i can only imagine so if you have if
you you know go outside a little bit and
you try to look at yourself you know
from a third party angle
what type of leader are you you know
what what type what what is sort of your
thought process behind the leadership
that you exert because i'm sure that as
you're so rigorously you know working on
you know in the engineering side i'm
sure that you're also very intentional
with the way that you lead others and
how you see leadership in your own
domain
yeah so i'm as a person i'm i'm a people
person so i i
like the technical side but i also like
people and
also my role not only as uh you know i
don't only lead people like personally
but also um my role as a control plane
leader is basically having interfaces
with the entire company right we got a
lot of data plane teams that need our
help to expose their features but we
also i don't know we're talking with
sales because we're doing the licensing
and we're talking with uh with our
devops because we are sending analytics
and we want
and we want it managed so i'm exerting
leadership in other directions as well
but uh but being a people's person and
being someone who's easy to talk to and
fun to talk to i hope
is something that really helps me uh
drive people forward you know because um
they trust me that i'm making uh i'm
making the right decisions and i'm also
i want the best for them like as a
person um i'm i'm looking for people who
are you know they they understand that i
care very very deeply about them as
people and i want to give them tasks
that they enjoy and not necessarily uh
tasks that will
that will bring value but maybe are
extremely boring or
not something that's fun to do or
something very tedious so i'm trying to
avoid giving such tasks and at least
controlling you know who's getting what
uh so they feel like their person they
keep personally developing right like if
i have a meta programming task because i
want someone to improve their meta
programming and we're working with the
language d which is very met programming
heavy so i want to make sure that every
person on the team experiences this type
of programming
not only because it's it improves the
product but also because it improves
them
no it's it's a new paradigm so i want
them to experience it i love it so if
you're looking today and and you you
know you have you know so many different
things that you can spend your time on
and you sort of are responsible for for
finding the right balance what do you
enjoy most you know where do you get the
most kick out of your
i think uh the most kick is still pair
programming with someone i think because
uh it's
yeah because you know i i don't i don't
get to do a lot of features alone now
right
if i'm programming by myself it's to
solve a specific bug it's usually a
one-line change or two-line change um
but and then you know when i'm coding
with someone from the team i'm both
helping them teaching them but also you
know experiencing more of the technical
side of what we're doing and i'm really
in love with code and with our code so
just seeing it again and again and again
always brings me joy
so i believe this is something i really
really enjoy um i also enjoy uh
conversations with uh with
um
like candidates to weka but not in the
early stages but like after we were
already you know past interview phases
and it's now time to sell the company uh
to them i am i really love these
conversations like you know we get to
brag a lot a lot about the team about
the company about the investors whatever
i love these conversations uh because we
usually have a lot to say
um i think these like
probably my favorite parts um i also
like even you know uh when i just
started working with weka the product
was not stable
uh so doing a lot of escalations and
managing a lot of these you know
customer incidents uh it was it was hard
but now that it happens a lot less
frequently because the product is a lot
more stable then i'm really enjoying it
when it happens even if it happens you
know middle of the night or early in the
morning it's you know it's like uh it
brings me back to like army days right
you're doing things in unorthodox hours
and it's really similar you know because
doing stuff you know
with cyber and having to be very
meticulous and very detail-oriented and
understand everything you're doing to
the last
to the last bit and modeling everything
is something that really translates to
what we're doing in production when
we're you know managing storage systems
that have petabytes of data on them so
incredible and you know it's really
scary you're connected to a system that
has two petabytes of used storage and
this is this is customers data and they
need it they really need it it's
business critical for them so
you really don't want to make mistakes
right a hundred percent and i think that
that's a perfect segue you know you're
you're in a very unique position and
where you're both you know working on
highly complex technologies and you know
what the industry today calls deep tech
at the same time you're you're working
on products that that have user
interfacing you know um
you have
user interfacing products where you have
to sort of bridge the gap in this
dissonance between you know the
complicated structure of the back end
versus the user experience you know on
the front end so so where where do you
sit with that and you know why why go
that route because most people who did
that i'm in the army and people that you
know that are so they're engineers like
you they don't necessarily go to this
place
yeah well i'm
you know i think even in the army i
really wanted things to be easy to use
you know it's it's not only and easy to
use usually also means easy to
understand but not necessarily
um
but
you know when i coded tools i really
wanted them to be easy to use because
people use them all the time and they
want things to be comfortable you know
they don't want to spend a lot of time
in your program they just wanted to work
for them
and
in weka like we got like these three
pillars of what the product stands for
so it's like performance scale and
simplicity because
storage is complicated like you don't
want people to when they need to they
start their workload they don't want 200
tunables and start you know
customizing everything to get every bit
of performance they really just want
plug and play
and uh and from that perspective in the
team we're doing the front end of the
product and we're doing like the cli and
the api and we want everything to be
simple for the customer so whether it
means counting the number of clicks they
do in the ui it's it's interesting
because
if i see that something that the
customer will need to do
twice every week and they need to click
10 times to do it it's like
i don't want them to spend so much time
on the on the product i just want them
to see you know sometimes maybe log in
see very high up time see very high
performance numbers be happy have like
this bird inside that's you know
chirping
um
so for me it's it's really about
doing stuff that the customer likes and
finds it simple and find enjoyable
and even it by the way means
having like the just the product itself
it should look good it should bring you
warm feelings when you look at it and
the color scheme is right and the pixels
are exactly you know where they need to
be
and uh and everything is written very
clearly and when you got an error or
something bad happens like customers
just they don't want to call support for
every tiny thing right they just want
the system to tell you what's wrong and
how you can fix it because
you know when you see when you see the
system tells you what's wrong you just
and how to fix you just do it i think
one of the interesting insights that
i've had you know in my on my journey
was the fact that you know transitioning
from falling in love with the code to
falling in love with the product and i
think that what you're touching on here
in the simplicity you know it's a it's a
great example of that because you know
we engineers have a tendency to fall in
love with code and with the technology
but now your responsibility as a team
leader as a group leader you know and
and overseeing a product you have to you
know get people to understand the bigger
picture of what they're doing and not
just the specific feature that they're
working on right so if you had to you
know
give sort of your two cents to to
engineers on on what they can do to sort
of improve that skill of branching out
to thirty thousand feet and fall in love
with the strategy and the product and
see their code as an enabler for that
what are some of your thoughts on that
well first of all
when you think of a task
you shouldn't think of
that you shouldn't start by thinking of
how i'm gonna code this and what's the
deep algorithm behind it but you should
start you know with with the stories
with the use cases with what the
customer is gonna do with this and how
does it fall in line with their flow
like usually when you're adding a new
feature to something it's not it's not
you know you're sitting in your little
box but the customer is going to run
seven boxes before your box and then
three more boxes after it so you want to
think about
how the experience looks for them
throughout
their you know like journey through your
program right because again
there's very very little amount of
features that will actually be you know
a standalone feature that the customer
just uses and usually it's part of the
flow so first of all you you must think
of the flow it's really important and
then how will the user see things how
will they experience uh errors and
always think about you know the the
0.001 percent that something goes wrong
so for for a system like ours something
such a bug that happens uh zero zero one
percent of times happens twice a week so
and then you need to think of these of
these error cases first of all how will
the customer respond so what what what
should they do if they encounter such
errors and how will we respond how to
maintain our features it's also very
important you know like you're coming to
help the customer that
you know something screwed up you you
want to help the customer how will you
be able to help the customer and this is
second and then reporting and analyzing
and you know in the control plane we got
like auditing and analytics and
statistics and we've got load and
alerting we've got loads of different
types of how the customer is going to
see different features so you want to
think about all of them because all of
them are important
i love it inspiration
you have to be creative in your work the
company is changing you know it's
growing very very quickly and and you
have a lot of responsibility to
continuously be inspired by things so
that you can then exert your inspiration
and inspire others around you where do
you get your inspiration from
where do you get my inspiration from
well it's a difficult question i guess
um
no it's a difficult question so first of
all it is you know we got a lot of smart
people in weka so just discussions with
people in weka gives you a lot of
inspiration people with with so much
time in the storage industry behind them
already so they understand how how
people think in that regard and you know
like also i don't think it's a shame to
just look at what the competitors do and
copy a little you know like if i see
their front end and it's sick it has
amazing features like i don't know i'm
really proud of our back end but i want
improvements in the front and i want
their features
it's not a shame to copy and do things
like others have done before you you
know even if they're your competitors
but usually what when i'm looking at
such a thing i'm always looking like how
can i do this like at least like 10
better so this looks just just a little
bit more excellent than what they did so
you know i have something to show off so
it's not just their features in our
colors but we also improved upon it and
did something more
um
i think major inspirations because it
was picasso
it was picasso said and then followed by
steve jobs a good artist copy a great
artist steal and i think the term steel
here is a little misleading but but but
there you know there's a reason why
picasso and steve jobs
exactly and at the end you know it's
about it's about providing the right
value and obviously you know in the
world of deep tech and and complicated
software that were that that you're
working on the role of you know the
front end of the user experience is just
to enable
the cool things to take place and to
make it accessible that is at the end
and danny i really want to thank you for
taking the time to to come here and
sharing your your own insights and you
know leadership within organizations as
an engineer i think it's fascinating and
thank you for providing me some good
minutes of entertainment growing up and
and thinking what and thinking why am i
not good enough to to be where he is so
thank you for the inspiration
and the motivation for that and uh and
stay safe and selfie best of luck with
black io thank you thank you so much for
having me
[Music]
you